it is time for the press preview see
what the papers are making of all take
you through the front pages as they
arrive uh we are joined this evening by
the daily mails consultant editor andrew
pearce and the broadcaster and former mp
anna subraine and they are going to be
with us from now until just before
midnight but let's take you through the
front pages that we have before we hear
from our guests on the matter of sue
gray's report that metro has the
headline we got away with it
paraphrasing i should say the words of a
former former senior downing street
official in a message to a colleague at
the time of the parties
the eye quotes from the report
describing a failure of leadership in
number 10 and indeed across whitehall
the guardian mentions the drinking
fights and vomiting that allegedly took
place at those gatherings
here's the ft
it describes the prime minister as
unbowed by the court's looted details
contained in the report
the mail says what many conservative
supporters believe
that boris johnson feels he has been
vindicated the headline
is that it
similar sentiments in the express and
they say really is this what all the
fuss is about
the government's insistence that it is
time to move on from the matter is
reflected in the telegraph uh with the
chancellor poised to announce additional
help for energy consumers
as the sun puts it
the party gate is over it urges the pm
to get on with the job of helping people
through the cost of living crisis
but as you would expect and the mirror's
taken event somewhat different that
boris johnson and their view is just
laughing at us all
another reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll be seeing on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you are
watching us and as mentioned uh we're
joined tonight by andrew pearce and anna
subray lovely to see you both wish it
was in the flesh but unfortunately we
still have to do it this way uh don't
wait um anna subray to your first your
pick uh starting with the guardian and
split it is it is the detail of what is
emerged today that i think a lot of
people will be focusing on and and
surprise surprise the guardian are
choosing to do that
yes absolutely and of course it
describes um the contents of sue gray's
report this long-awaited report drinking
fights vomiting all in the day's work
says the headline there and that's
basically the conclusion that she comes
to um that there was this culture of
partying which i think actually in
normal times
should concern everybody and would be
clearly wrong in any workplace
but in the middle of the cove pandemic
really is utterly unacceptable and will
will appall um i think
almost everybody across the country that
this was going on
and on such a scale and clearly within
the knowledge of the prime minister
gray's investigated 15 parties though as
your sam coates has quite rightly
pointed out it doesn't seem that the
abba party
was part of her investigation talk about
that perhaps later but of course what
gray does is that she absolutely nails
the responsibility and it's a failure of
political leadership i.e the buck stops
of course it does with the prime
minister and i cannot think of any other
prime minister in my living memory who
faced with such a condemnation this
report wouldn't have done the right
thing perhaps some time ago certainly
now
and resigned
andrew take us to the front of um the
eye and it references of course that
failure of leadership that was in sue
gray's report but if i'm remembering
correctly sue gray did say it was a
failure of leadership by political
leaders but also by officials
yes she does she it's both but and she
makes pop the point about the political
leadership she says to the top of
politically so she's she's clearly
referring to the prime minister that the
the officials clearly it's the cabinet
secretary simon casey who's still there
he was at one of the parties but he
didn't get fined uh i think it's less so
the chancellor who i still think was
very unfortunate to get hit with a fine
in in any case but uh
i think the reason a lot of people think
tori and peter thinking the prime
minister's out of the woods now is
because her conclusions about the
failure of political leadership
and the culture of drinking she'd made
that point in her interim report which
we saw in january and in some ways the
interim report was more devastating
because it was much shorter and smaller
and that was the first time we'd heard
those expressions so although we've got
more color now about what went on one
party where someone threw up and people
outrageously being rude or disrespectful
to security staff and cleaners um i
don't think she's shed she's not she's
not there's nothing that i've read that
would be a killer blow because then lots
of glory and peace carrying off to sigre
and brady the chairman of the 1922
committee who demand a confidence vote
in boris johnson's leadership
i mean as we as we take a quick look at
the front page of the metro in their
headline paraphrasing one of the senior
officials involved in all of this saying
we got away we got away with it i mean
we are in a situation now aren't we
where anyone who picks up a newspaper
must have not must know about this story
and must have arrived at a conclusion
about this story already yep as andrew
says there's more detail there's more
color that is coming out including this
particular line but it's not going to
shift anyone's opinion is it
well i think i think i agree with andrew
one that i think he makes a good point
and you know it's part of the clever
management not by johnson because he
couldn't manage
anything he's so hopeless but those
around him have clearly done a good
management job of of of how this story
has developed and the more we've learned
of it by basically just
just boring people ordinary folk now
that may well be the case that there's a
wary you know weariness rather amongst
ordinary folk um
what really matters as andrew said and
others now are commenting on is where
the conservative party is in parliament
and if they haven't got the decency to
understand just how appalling this is
this terrible failure of political and i
accept also senior officials as well
it's extraordinary nobody's fallen on
their silent sword and done the decent
thing it's what tory mps are going to do
and the simple truth is if if they don't
get rid of boris johnson keep him on the
british people will get rid of him and
in fact he'll increasingly become such a
liability to the conservative party
labour can be pretty much guaranteed
that they're going to win the next
general election he'll be one of the
best things for the labour party
i mean andrew i wonder if you might want
to pick up on that as we reflect on on
the front of the the f team and they're
describing the prime minister as an
bowed and that seems to be a a fairly
sensible and fairly safe
characterization of how he feels at the
moment but we are still
uh going through a cost of living crisis
his to-do list is as long as my arm i
mean the prime minister is he entirely
out of the woods
yeah he's damaged there's no doubt about
it and the report is unsavory um but
again uh i think people are weary there
is fatigue about partygate you talk to a
lot of people and they say oh for god's
sake move on we know about all this and
and again i don't think there seems to
be any startling new revelations we know
that sure
swing was damaged all the rest
i think he has got a lot on his plate i
think the damage will the dangers for
boris johnson are the by-elections
coming up next month i think they'll
lose both of
them lose and you'll just just just just
interact just interrupt yeah
is there though an answer to the
question that tobias would put to the
prime minister today you know name
another prime minister that having gone
through all of this would not have
resigned and probably resigned a long
time ago
well i don't think
you can't imagine margaret's actual or
theresa may uh being in downey street
when there were parties the night before
prince prince phillips funeral which i
think was one of the most shameful of
them all
and that went until four in the morning
now boris johnson wasn't there he was in
checkers he was a long way from it but
no i can't imagine any other prime
minister would have done that but and
but we've always said about boris
johnson haven't we he's been he people
factor in a lot of different um
they make different they've made
allowances for him but i think he's at
the end of the road with those
allowances now he's used up a lot of
goodwill he's not a cat with nine lives
you know neil he's a cat with 99 and
he's used up quite a few of those lives
although
your paper the mail i mean their
headline today tomorrow i should say
is that it i i suspect reflecting
reflecting the view of quite a few
people perhaps about the content of the
suicide report so so much had it been
built up welcome back to the press
preview andrew and anna still with us um
and andrew let's turn to you the prime
minister wants to be getting on with the
job we will allow him the opportunity to
do so uh so tell us exactly how he will
be getting on with the job front page of
the telegraph
well a lot of the papers have got this
the telegraph are reporting that
tomorrow the chancellor will make
statements of commons it's the last day
before the recess for the queen's
jubilee
a package of measures around 10 billion
pounds worth of measures to help
alleviate the worst effects of the fuel
crisis and if you recall in that rather
limp spring budget mini budget that he
brought out in april part of the help
was from october people would get 200
pounds
uh off the of their energy bills uh but
you'd have to repay it over five years
so that's part of the the loan thing is
going to be scrapped and we think he's
going to increase maybe even double the
payment from 200 to 400 pounds there's
also going to be help i think on
universal credit for the poorer families
and it's a recognition that with the
with the
when we discovered the details of the
new price cap when it's being lifted in
october what did the off gem regulator
say the other day it could go up another
800 pounds they're having to move very
very quickly also rather conveniently of
course the day after sue gray's report
which will help them really move on
politically
oh andrew you're professional cynic i
wonder if anna might perhaps agree with
you
in terms of the timing
of course it does this is the most
blatant management of news to the
advantage of johnson so he yet again
gets off the hook but what's what's
really striking to me is papers like the
telegraph like the express and the daily
mail all of whom should have bylines by
michael mouse because they've turned
themselves into mickey mouse cartoons of
of just this sycophantic
running with stuff to support johnson
not actually doing their job and they
don't understand
how damning this report is but it's the
breach
we understand to be being announced
tomorrow additional relief for dealing
with the energy bills i mean that's
going to be welcome by anyone
all that i
care when it comes to this cost of
living crisis is that measures are
introduced that alleviate the appalling
situation that a lot of families who are
the poorest in our society find and any
measures that are undertaken to relief
the effects on the poorest in our
society i welcome but it's not as simple
as just this there's much more that this
government should be doing particularly
looking at benefits
and how we make sure that those who are
the most vulnerable suffer the least in
this terrible cost of living crisis but
it would help if we had a competent
honest truthful decent prime minister
well can i just come back
i'm sure i'm sorry because we've only
got 20 seconds to go we will be
returning to this topic next uh uh
andrew anna i do want to defend you i
just want to defend my newspaper against
anna's outrageous attacks
we will definitely do that literally
i've literally ten seconds to go andrew
i am nothing if not a man of my word and
we promise you a right of reply uh there
has been i think it's fair to say some
criticism of the way that the male has
gone after kier starmer full-throated
and perhaps less so with boris johnson
but you wanted to respond very directly
to what anna was saying what i wanted to
say i mean
anna subrie's it's always intensely
personal with anna subray about boris
johnson we know she couldn't stand him
that's why she quit the tory party set
up an independent party and
unceremoniously was dumped by her
electorate at the last election but on
the mail and the tory party we've always
been a potentially difficult friend for
the conservative party anna doesn't read
the mail enough to know that we've been
intensely critical of the government's
response to the cost of living crisis
intensely critical of the decision to
raise national insurance and we were
right to pursue kierstama because
kirstama was not investigated by the
police he was assessed by the police and
when the police saw the new evidence
hang on when the police saw the new
evidence they decided that they would
investigate after all and then the
labour party had this astonishing
revelation that angela rainer who they
said hadn't been there jeremy mistake
was it the durham hall with kirsten now
that's all under investigation and it
was legitimate the mail to pursue it
i never mentioned it
i don't want us to spend the next 50
minutes you two going back and forth on
this but i will let you have a chance
just to kind of answer that point there
make the point you were about to well i
just said i never mentioned kirsten
i'm talking about the british prime
minister and trust in politics trust has
been broken by these rules and all i'll
say to andrew is this to say on your
front page is that it well it may not be
for the daily mail but for your readers
who made extraordinary sacrifices during
the coveted pandemic they could go to
funerals they couldn't say and hold the
hand of a loved one who was dying
extraordinary as i say their sacrifices
you dismiss it what's happening about
downing street blatant breaches of the
rules as somebody else said sticking two
fingers out basically at the british
people
photographer
i'm right
right just finally
as i said i really genuinely don't spend
the next 45 minutes of the program doing
this but i do
we're going to move on to the quick
question as identified by both of our
guests this evening the question whether
or not it matters to voters well this is
what some people told our political
correspondent liz bates
during a game of croquet in west
oxfordshire
there he is this is his birthday that's
the head of the civil service
these are sort of sandwiches drinks
that's him and the chancellor
they've certainly had a gathering and
well then he should face the
consequences
we had an 18th birthday a 21st birthday
and a 25th wedding anniversary
all of which
weren't celebrated
that was his
what 56th birthday big deal
i'd give him um
three months
i think it's uh i think it's run it's a
run its day
but let's bring you just a little bit
more of what some of the papers are
saying
uh page five of the daily express leo
mckinstry providing further analysis of
the situation claim that boris johnson
was able to absorb his punishment
without dropping to the canvas during
the due to the sheer passage of time
exhausting much of the public
similarly the times claims that the
prime minister seems to be weathering
the criticisms of partygate describing
him uh well quentin let's describe him
as an uncombed corpulent figure
but one that nonetheless was plodding
onwards a hunched husky in a blizzard
back to to andrew and anna a hunched
husky in a blizzard anna what do you
make of that assessment of the prime
minister
well it is interesting because i've
never known anybody who brushes their
hair with a balloon until i saw boris
johnson
and i know we can make light here and i
know people's health safety doesn't
matter but actually it does
it matters when you're
what do you the prime minister for
goodness sakes and you should at least
try and look half decent and he just
looks like a shambolic mess
that's because he is a mess amongst many
other things
um andrew
the prime minister clearly uh wouldn't
ever want to go without a fight
do you anticipate that there will over
the coming couple of days be a little
bit more of a trick we've had a couple
of names coming out suggesting they've
submitted their letters to the chairman
of the 22s i mean do you have any
expectation that we will come anywhere
close to the magic number
no but no because i don't think i think
beth rigby in her summing up was right
there was no killer blow in sue grey's
report no silver bullet uh and uh and
it's i think a lot of the response will
be what how they respond to the cost of
living crisis we're we're going to find
that out in the next 24 hours in the
commons and
and a test as i said earlier in the
programme will be the by-elections which
i think they'll lose both of them
particularly the one which would be most
painful would be the one in devon where
the ghastly mp had been watching porn
for god's sake in the commons chamber
and there's a majority there about 24
000 and if that evaporates caused
pressure but it is mid-term they've been
in power for 12 years and all governing
parties lose by elections so i sense
having thought if the sugree report had
been a lot more serious for boris
johnson that he could have been
potentially in trouble i think he's
weathered probably the worst of the
storm if you can forgive that cliche